welcome to this video this is yet
another Christmas bonus video and Tom I
was trying to do some let's keep it sing
for a while but somehow when I was on
and at the time there wasn't there
wasn't something great to watch okay
you never know if the games really are
great if the names involved are great
but yeah I didn't want to do cubed sing
on on a player you probably don't know
so let's have a look here this is with
white bread awesome yeah so Sarabande
very well known us Grandmaster you
probably also know him as a commentator
nowadays is very much involved in doing
commentary form the US Championships and
various top level tournaments but he is
also a regular blitz player on the ICC I
have played him quite a number of times
with various accounts and I can tell you
that he's really really good at blitz
I mean it's also a good player in the
classical time control and very good
blitz in this game however he overlooked
Quincy v check and this was really
important for me now why does support
down and somewhat tied down with his
pieces note that this is a three minute
game it's not five minutes chess so the
time if management is even more crucial
than in five minute yeah like a son not
playing at the moment yeah well he is
probably concerned about his Queen
having no square that's true but still
you should should play white cannot
really attack the Queen at the root
maybe that's route a one create you okay
one sort of firm yeah just
eternally attacking the Queen does a bit
of it like a perpetual rook a one Queen
see - Roxy one this could be could be
wrong yeah I think this should be at all
if white goes for that okay one Queen c2
rope c1 not sure that white has more
okay he's trying from one very young
come counted comfort of combative you
have that probably butchering this
pronunciation well very young
enterprising choice and white is just
two points down he should have taken the
draw but okay it's not much use in those
blitz games to to play play play for
draws well just mixing it up is often
more fun this looks very tricky though
yeah after the knight move how how do
you protect the knight on D to I don't
really see it play Bishop III but like
cannot take on a one and just continue
to play rook takes a one Bishop d2 loop
t1 you know that's also not bad as he
falls under huge pressure so there's
just this pawn falling black only needs
to watch yeah of the time track some
getting tricky like it's completely
winning but he's on 14 seconds also note
that if you look at the ratings is
rating foolin Auto pairing on also the
regular Blitzer bullet ratings they all
have their own sort of scaling that
means that if you look at 2400 ready
check well that's good stuff no check
yeah why does white is okay again and
he's got 90 more time so you would not
chime probably check last four fits on
top yeah one on time one second left
yeah what I was getting at is that every
rating or every discipline 3 minute 5
minute regime it has his own rating so
that this 2459 my Sarah one is really
excellent in 3 minute in the 3 minute
Auto pairing I often if I'm in good
shape I get to this kind of ratings in 5
minute but in the 5 minute - 4 is really
good but not outstanding - 460 is really
outstanding in 3 minute okay here's our
was playing black against bacon butty
from from United Kingdom and his plate
um something similar to the chicken
quite aggressive way to play and white
instantly attacked the pawn which Sarah
one just took yeah maybe you can just
take it and keep it with Bishop e6
coming they don't really know how to
take with the king but he's probably
arguing that he could get the King to c7
Fischer b6 and well you need to keep the
pawn I think if you're just young yeah
if you just give the pawn back and white
is just clearly better and I suspect
that this is the case anyway white looks
fine to me here
he's got good chance is to get the pawn
back and
yeah natural moves are available bishop
yeah Bishop f4 yeah this is what I
wanted the same and just sure about that
I really would have liked to get the
pawn back with the group to c1 or
something okay
but it's interesting anyway but how does
white make any progress here I think
this wasn't good too to not try to get
the pawn back quickly how do you get it
back now I mean Sarah well it's a
notorious pawn grabber and usually
really shouldn't give him an extra pawn
without any compensation is an excellent
technical player that's a some main um
main strength
yeah it's not like he's a one-trick pony
but he really excels in positional
strategical positions and in technical
ones he returned the policy three but in
the process he coordinated his pieces
and still has the better pawn structure
White has the isolated pawns on a 2 and
C 3 and the doubled pawns on the e-file
while black structures completely solid
and doesn't have any weaknesses he just
aims to to trade more yeah and this is
an interesting technical game now White
has improved the pawn structure a bit
check Jim I think I'm not sure I've
maybe the worst silver but he can't
stuff a white I mean he can still play
be 585 before this kind of this kind of
advance getting a peso then I don't know
of course that one
yeah this is much stronger much stronger
now you get the a porn rolling a 5 up to
a three and then you can enter with the
king
check yeah and now prepare King c3 is
the idea you have fun good chances to
pick up the pawns
- sure p8 I know and then you can take
your phone we are king at King III I'm
thinking III is probably winning okay
yeah I didn't like - didn't like that
too much why would you play six hmm yeah
well just by far the better technical
player so I'm cautious yeah okay now we
have the dreaded wrong-colored bishop so
it's a it's a draw now
yes sir I'll actually draw I'd offer to
draw so now they know they have drawn so
um yeah I think he mr. William is sure
but
I didn't like that one so much if you if
you look at this why not
King III yeah King III is also the
computer suggestion yeah unfortunately
Sarah one has disconnected so we only
got got like two or three games out of
all of this player let's um let's check
if there are some other strong players
yeah there are some maybe wrote King
let's follow Road King he's playing some
more threesomes 3-minute games Road King
does not have a name in the I is playing
on the SSC for ages the play team also
the number of times he's very high rated
and and the regular blitz rating like
3400 this is um yeah this is nakamura
territory so he's obviously a capable
blitz player we see that he and in the
three-minute pool to Simula are the same
otto praying food that just heroin had
just played he's got to 478 which just
mentioned is pretty high rating so let's
see what happens is playing Tetrarch
tetra Tetrarch let's see who's got a
name in there nope australia right okay
all this guy has an excellent 5-minute
rating to 5 something ok let's see what
we got here got a very close position it
it came from from
from over to Benoni the Czech Benoni
were black him except some space some
space problems but he's got a very solid
and sturdy position you sometimes have
long term chances for proactivity but
it's a very yeah it's something you need
patience for like with night hmm tries
to exchange one pair of nights to
relieve some of the pressure an
important features that white has got
this bishop on g2 that it's not doing so
much quite often it's activated with
Bishop age 3 and now we see that see
that coming and now black must be
cautiousness
g5 yeah he tries to put it on dark
squares check
yeah this looks tricky the King on g6
and and everything black needs to defend
very accurately he maybe it's okay but
it's obviously I'm quite a risky way to
proceed
yeah Queen g5 Knight h4 his winning for
white knight as well
King edge six rook f6 he blows out that
yeah Road King was quick to spot it
check so made next move with rook age
six black resigns not sure I'm following
a road king so if he's starting new
games we'll follow that the videos only
on five minutes so I hope to see some
more games
yeah lots of channel viewers some have
requested to keep its own a camera this
is difficult nowadays he's not playing
so much on the ICC is concentrating more
on classical chess and okay money see
it's not so far away from being a very
serious candidate for a world
championship match so he really should
focus on better too - yeah to get a
match against council okay so we have a
semi Slav here this Bishop d6 line is
some bit old-fashioned the line that
wrote King him has played but it's not
necessarily bad it's just a bit a bit
passive in comparison black cam suffers
from this somewhat ugly bishop on c8 and
quite often in the Queen's Gambit this
is the main the main point you need to
get this bishop c8 a
and to be six is a typical way to do
that he maybe em will do that next
smooth yeah I expect Queen h4 no no yeah
well he probably will do Bishop b2
the salt so good move because his heaven
quite often is a good square for the
queen and now the bishop can show this
opponent square but in general this type
of pawn structure that can arise from
various openings some believe to be
rather okay for black it can often arise
from the French defense sometimes from
Queens gambit structures like him
typically it's a French structure of the
terrazzo and the Reuben Reuben steam
variation okay
white has of course better peace
activity the knight on d5 especially is
a good piece so what black should try to
do is to exchange some pieces that are
active and try to get rid of some of
this piece pressure
yeah Bishop h6 now is some simple
reaction but this is also interesting
going for the Queen activation way
between h6 even or Bishop g5 Queen h4
can also be in a DM yeah Queen c5 this
mostly connects the rooks
so that you can play Rupert e8 you know
the Bishop f6 problem attacking rook
that one yeah why not
oh the Queen does this a bit bit of a
problem
maybe Queen five yeah I think Black has
succeeded in
relieving lots of pressure queen is nice
on e5 the bishop is nice on c6 I think
black should be about equal him nothing
to worry about at least it's not so
clear what white is supposed to do now
the Queen on edge three years a bit off
site one problem is that black might
even yes simply invade on V - yeah Queen
B - this is maybe an idea now Queen on
b2 is very annoying very quickly played
get sort of fighting fire with fire but
if you go look at you one what exactly
is happening rock t1 rock to you on
Queen c2 with us decimate threatened on
d1 and rook t1 Bishop t1 Queen e1 yeah
with Queenie form and that's it made on
g2 yeah white somehow lost the truck him
white resigns yeah this went downhill
really quickly around here there was not
much going on
maybe 97 is a step in the wrong
direction that some difficult to say but
at the end that didn't really help white
lost some time and needed to retreat the
rook and then we had the situation where
the Queen was invading he could probably
have defended himself but I was
expecting Bishop d4 actually okay get
another game against this tetra church
rock player yeah this time we get a Slav
mainline Slav with D takes e4
and 195 it's one of the main lights
three is the other one night a six is
usually answered this is not so great
actually he didn't he doesn't love him
he does not know the theory it seems now
e5 this is quite okay for black better
is 73 at least that that's what I'm what
I'm knowing about it
yeah Queen T for this that was a night
before check there should be six
probably it's not so clear that white is
some that what can can even develop
easily him yeah Bishop e6 after Bishop
takes before this Bishop takes e4 I can
go to g6 but then Knight X t4 is at
least possible yeah might really am good
confused by this particular move honor
and forgot to play 73 a black is
spending lots of time iam I mean my my
time management is really bad I know
that but it's some do twosome yeah do to
to them to the commentary so once in
ramallah spend time just explaining what
I'm what I'm doing or thinking about and
I could could move faster than if I
didn't do that and but this guy is
taking it to extremes it's a three
minute game need to move cannot spend so
long even understand that he probably
thinks that what's position is very
suspicious but still wonder now one of
the half minutes is half you
time the 3-minute game yeah know what I
think can take on t4 check how this is
also interesting I didn't see that at
all
95 maybe 95 if the night meeting where
does 36 night go
and this also Queen takes d4 it's the
interesting point
Queen d4 Queenie 492 and this is a bit
tricky I think
mm-maybe Knight f5 yeah I probably need
to play Knight f5 where where would you
go yeah and now that's the check on d3
check check Knight f4 King f2 Queen b6
checking g3 I don't know check all this
can easily lead to nothing for black if
you don't yeah 26 maybe an endgame is
not so comfortable
the King in the middle is not a problem
then and interestingly plays simulated
with the knight coming to deform yeah I
hardly prefer white here but it's
probably random it's nothing it's
nothing here
96 is coming and if you need to exchange
the night there's simply nothing going
on no this is this is really really a
very Jewish
yeah both sides have a majority to fish
and probably this is what what is some
it's probably the general way to go here
I still prefer white slightly to be
honest the queenside is not so easy to
do to to move and maybe g5 now yeah
white is better now you got your
majority is far more dangerous can take
and maybe play route k1 to enter on the
a file and the C pawn yeah this is also
interesting intending up d6 well very
hard to play it in the precise the
precise way with this little time group
d6 check may take a 600 b6 check check
yeah it's a matter of seconds now White
has got 16 black has got 10 seconds
considering that he was basically
spending all his time in the only
opening black really did a great job
in staying staying on the ward and maybe
he's got some some drawing chance though
yeah King e6 check it six seconds this
is the problem black for fits on time he
was really really quick at the end the
Australian guy he got
I got here rooting down to four for
something seconds and considering that
here yeah look at this he was down to
118 and then playing like like an
absolute speed demon
all right Road King has disconnected
unfortunately and let's see if I can
find some other player yeah welcome back
and I took her took her a break him who
are looking for more games to keep its
own and I got a call which I had to take
and now I'm back and I found him
something worthwhile to Givens it's a
three minute game I'm tone black player
is the one I'm following not sure how
many games he will play but let's see
check this Grandmaster let's let me help
you
for bhakti play the witch Bosnia and his
yeah the ratings that is mentioning here
are to 640 know around around this okay
that's him in this position here he
enjoys an extra pawn and then I just saw
that the black opening was rather funky
okay let's see in the upcoming games if
he keeps playing this type of stuff age
5 and a 5
hmm you up like like to move here I can
just take because f2 hangs at the end
with ya winning winning the house so I
can just take this additional pawn yeah
okay one it's a good solution Queen
default also a good move
check your king h1 and then rook a one
probably the queen is very nicely placed
on d4 of course
you know like I should probably win this
as well but Roque one seems simpler to
me
with this chick how does queen bee - so
he blundered Blunden two-piece basically
what what was happening what no I need
to I need to look what check check
King p8 what what why didn't take the
rook how strange is that and then he
made a pre move Queen e7 because of
course every normal person would take
the rook and Queen e7 was just
blundering it now this is Sun bleaching
check check check
this is the current position so why does
completely winning now with Queen
against against all Czech Czech Republic
I have just earlier today check you
didn't really learn it why the only
needs to avoid stay night you really
should manage Queen f7 mate no mate twin
GA chant Wow check may only need to see
one mate so completely wacky game let's
see what do a which is now playing b3
sort of white double fianchetto playing
the machine gun from the US we have a
name or Fonzo on Maeda white is playing
a sort of hippopotamus reversed but with
a quick G form so the Sun is interesting
maybe with F for coming
25 year maybe a 4 and then f4 f4 looks a
bit loose what can also play deform and
return to a normal position yeah this
looks a bit loose to me
not sure those Queen b6 type of moves
but not sure that they're really and now
D form white is good enough yeah that's
a nice position the weirdness is over
now white is just it just better and has
occupied to the center only later than
than usual yeah very nice formation on
the FL tripling but still black is quite
solid chant oh he just sucked apiece
yeah it is dangerous of the slave for
black but maybe you can take twice G f
GF Bishop takes rook takes Queen takes
t2 yeah now that's 96 I think black
should have taken probably but 95 is a
real shocker move no it's no surprise
that he maybe didn't react in the the
best possible way yeah I just
just take the pawn
and now tries to support the center
maybe just back with the knight on
Knight f3 this is also a good idea
activating the d2 night it wasn't doing
much and can join the play on the
kingside on f3
yeah very complicated position
why should be better because of the
strong light on d6 and his advantage in
space but it's not and I don't really I
don't really think it's an easy win at
least I don't see it maybe in 94 to f6
is kind of plan
I is going for 95 again but I'm not sure
how dangerous this release takes takes
Queen g7 okay yeah it's difficult black
only has 40 seconds so he needs to
instantly decide mostly based on
intuition on if you should take it or
leave it on a5 the night before but the
knight on d5 is always protecting f6 on
Queen takes the 300 G - this is very
strong check get his side
check check
yeah and no black is a piece up oh he
isn't
I forgot about Carina 3j it still looks
nice for black take f3 take before but
it's not a clear-cut winner at blankets
down to ten seconds
check yeah they're here now this is
tricky I mean maybe black can eliminate
all material to draw check J get the
pawn so for a draw check yeah rook F to
mate he managed nice very nice that
black actually managed to to win the
game
yeah and white players disconnected yeah
bit of a disappointing game for him I
mean he had very nice position and then
it all fell apart and it's never nice
okay let's check if there are some other
keep it Singh opportunities
let's see who's dr. like sunder cousin
from very high ratings let's see what is
playing I mean what kind of time control
grandmas the doctor let's shade in I
like some doc cousin I don't know this
guy me there's so many GM's
he's playing black against an Indian
player Sean Nikki oh check no name and
all the sky
check GM doctor is too for a teachers
are very high rating in the three-minute
pool check three minute is very popular
Kieran and we just witness the draw
perpetual basically yeah black is very
active with the night so white better
take the perpetual I hope forget some
more games from the sky
let's see now against machine gun the
player who just a couple of minutes ago
won against the Bosnian GM fedorovich
and we got an Italian game Castle is
very unusual Knight takes e4 is just a
pawn I'm amazed that people might didn't
I take this line gets played quite often
against me and it's simply incorrect but
I can take the pawn and have just as an
extra pawn okay we have a different
position black is also okay here but
it's not he has taught one the poem and
the central pawn is quite important he
could have played g5 94 here but it's a
bit risky
he chose a solid setup details if I have
surprises me I probably would have taken
with a knight and always try to get rid
of this knight on c6 yeah it's not a
great piece on c6 because it always
looks at the default be four squares and
this is also why he now reroute sit to
g6 an interesting way to play and note
that black has not Castle short yet
maybe he's thinking about canceling long
Bishop out and you know you're canceling
long is difficult yeah Black has a very
comfortable position in this position
type the knight is a good piece
the problem is that the bishop does not
have anything to attack most of blacks
pawns are unknown dark squares and the
bishop is mostly pointing into thin air
while the knight always some yahwah can
try to take up different posts and
attack
take care enemy pawns this is also
interesting is playing in a technical
technical manner even g6 is move I mean
not not really thinking that it is great
but yeah this is this is much better
of course PG 6 was threatened to win the
bishop so white needed to to play that
here g3 to secure the square on a3 and
here you know black is active but can
you win or can you win us a bit Fedora
can you increase increase your advantage
Lycus is better on the on the default
but how much is this worth ready you are
controlling the default and that's night
a4 and I think it's playing a really
nice escape discard attacking here now
d4 is a big weakness so the like likes
heavy pieces now can invade rock d3
where's the Queen going
he had a queen strapped yeah it's always
difficult to say with any certainty but
this look like an excellent game of
Jackie really outplayed his opponent
positionally like just as an extra queen
very nicely very nicely play it even now
the little tactics yeah
they weren't really necessary but
tonight sounds so nice yeah this was a
real distraction white player got
completely wiped out and very quickly
around here you should be able to put up
some some defense but here it's it's
very very problematic I mean before and
Seaforths it's really a weak defense but
this night I don't have any I cannot
draw any arrows in this Cupid same
scenario maybe if I'm not sure this was
a good idea okay well we have a new game
started this GM again with wide against
international master schnappi she not be
from Germany does kleiner Coco dear the
Luther crocodile yeah this is from from
from hips single that was popular in
Germany ah this is a long time ago maybe
eight years it was about this little
crocodile Concha nappy all right so
let's see um while schnappi has played
modern defense g6 and then a 6 b 5 and
so on
but the white player has played in the
most aggressive aggressive possible
fashion just playing a four pawns attack
not not a bad idea
but always need to be cautious that you
don't overextend yeah white has played
many pawn moves and while this can be
the start of an really fierce attack it
also means that you have weakened many
squares for instance if you look at the
white camp just long-term
he's got weak squares on C form C 3 d 3
e 3 and so on
so if black blacks pieces can invade
White's position much later then this
can be really backfiring on the other
hand black doesn't really have yeah many
active pieces so it's not like he's
about to exploit there was a long term
weaknesses interesting yeah f5 I was
just about to say that this looks very
dangerous Queen d2 is a threat now to
just attack the knight and win it and
yeah now we need to go back to g8 and
our White's position looks overwhelming
every piece in play you got the center
yeah probably this position is some it's
very good for white but though you need
to be precise it's a shame that in this
kibitzing scenario I cannot draw a rose
but this is just how it is
yeah I I really like where it's
positioned because of the space and so
on the bishops but how do you actually
get ahead yeah he didn't really have a
good idea as well the a3 is a
strengthening move on general grounds
protecting before but it's not really
doesn't smell a recitation of blacks
position yeah but blacks play is
difficult
he can hardly hardly move maybe Knight G
to f6 or something yeah okay one C form
this is a good square yeah since white
decided to get rid of the rooks it's
probably not a bad idea the rook on a8
was always attacking the e3 pawn he went
for a technical idea with the knight
discovery but hmm that that's tricky now
Queen d2 if black takes on d5 I can take
b5 that's the knight attacking the Queen
Bishop takes Queen takes as a check wins
instantly Wow what is black is supposed
to do now yeah I think Knight takes d5
now with the temple yeah this is not bad
for white of course I just thought that
my cakes b5 was more forceful Queen d3
probably attacking it yeah
this was the idea of course he takes on
b5 and now the current rate is is
winning for white the two paths are
supported by the bishop pairs is a win
yeah this is a winning end game with
good technical play Bishop c6 probably
and then push the beep on
maybe it's already promoting two
connected outside passes supported by
the bishop pair is almost always a
waiting for effects on time ie was done
on time I didn't really look at the
clock to be honest I was just looking at
the position her black has no way to
save him so let's say night moves and
probably you can just push the pawn how
are you going to just stop that maybe
just just promoting not sure that this
is the easiest technically but it's a
good good way to play yeah fortunately
the white player who really played some
strong games has disconnected so need to
to look for to look for more whos
playing whos playing dr. steel hammer so
this is one of the Klitchko in Klitschko
brothers nickname but what is this guy
playing that's let's see it's a GM
anyway from russia seven name nope
that's a flea new new handle but he's
playing regular blitz here with two 941
so this is quite nice of course playing
it indian GM no name but three three
thousand and it's not bad at all yeah we
have this very typical pawn structure
rising from the catalan opening well
white has three against them three
against two
and enjoys a slight edge but it's not
much like him usually just proceed with
them simplifications and shouldn't be in
big trouble
yeah dr. steel hammer the Klitschko
brothers so I interested in chess and
they can't play chess not quite sure how
well they they can play but they are
friends with Vladimir Kramnik quite
often you see you see pictures of chrome
neck but the glitch goes hmm yeah Knight
takes before that was Queen c3 so black
just retreated not sure maybe yeah maybe
95 and taking two important points yeah
white points and I look slightly all the
way extended but not sure that you can
really make something out of that green
a to calculus queen f2 a let's see for
saying you just win the c4 pawn I just
I only saw that no like him just take C
form yeah this is a very very
problematic position check I'm Daisy
drawn oh then they draw they drew okay
well I think that the Russian play
offered to draw being a minute down in
this endgame I mean it was a minute up
sorry he was a pawn but had a minute the
compensation is a bit of a sudden end
here what I don't get is I mean okay the
guy offers a draw because he doesn't
want to win this this very bad position
on time why don't why don't they play
3-1 then so they can play out those kind
of position if you don't feel
comfortable playing on time I mean I
have sympathy for that I don't really
like to play on time those positions
myself then just playing from
they play this challenge system and they
can choose whatever time control they
want they are not tied to the time
control of the the pool
Bishop d5 now how do you protect the
rook is this a trick Queen Queen
something an admission yeah maybe maybe
this one Queen b6 looks a little bit bit
awful at least at first it looks a bit
strange with the bishop on e5 but
interesting why not Bishop d7
check
I know no why should win the Queen c6 if
the Queen Queen takes c6 simply Quincy
697 what black gets a new queen but
Queen B - now it's a very simple
solution okay yeah just take the purse
just take the the piece
it couldn't be too would've exchange
Queens so this is what I thought would
be okay with them put an additional
piece okay so does this wasn't a good
game I didn't understand in this
position after why it took here
why didn't he play Bishop e7 I can
this didn't work I wanted to examine
this game is impossible to do that I am
I didn't understand why why didn't it
play Bishop b7 isn't this just winning
the Queen I mean wins the Queen
instantly black should win I don't I
don't see a big point here this is not
to move I mean it's a pin I don't know
very strange Bishop e7 look good okay
let's see who else is playing it seems
that this guy is at least taking a break
we have Yaakov Nora wits playing our
camp is not not connected anymore
just death to just disconnected and we
have Julio Becerra playing I was playing
a 15 minute game that's a bit long
ok but what do we have molecule splaying
bullet yeah I don't really like a bullet
him it's a bit difficult to accommodate
Goldmoon Tucson but not playing at the
moment Hungarian chess and my old
nemesis Oleg ass okay come on let's
let's have a brief look at all that it's
the same the guy always has the same
games
what is this 5 points 5 points yeah
white is a bit better because of the
potential passer on the edge farm at
least has got 1 minute more the clock at
you will play everything on time of
course check
hmm yeah this was a strange why why did
Blake allow her ATM yeah white is
completely winning now the ball is just
promoting yeah you cannot cannot take on
edge five black resigns okay let's see
if we get another game that keep
checking if other players are online
that you could could follow following
all the gas is really not what you want
to do it's simply not so much fun
this integrator not playing
we have Ohio breeze wgm another tone
scheme the multiple be us women champion
yeah come on let's see what she's doing
what kind of oops which is not connected
that's strange
it does not get refreshed that often
not people leaving the server we can we
can try Hungarian chess are playing
against Monday Goran friend of mine and
Hungarian chess is rook up but check
okay we'll manage 9 seconds he will
manage to to Greg the pawns and now just
push the edge point of the Jeep on white
resigns let's see if this guy is playing
some more games yeah it's not not so
easy to to get interesting games to
kibbutz on so many many title players on
are you here to kill the young here we
can't follow this guy Kilian Carlo
tomorrow from Italy one of the frequent
opponents that that have all the time in
the 5-minute pool and he's playing a 5
minute game a very strong blitz player
to 450 here in the pool and is playing
machete machete you just beeped with the
wrong Mexican machete kills and machete
don't text yeah machete don't takes this
is from the first first part I was like
that
the shells became so let's see what what
this position check is like kitty I just
got an exchange back he had was an
exchange down but the white has a very
nice position just look at the bishop on
d4 against the the night on on a4 and
you got the H point I think this is
complete when H bone is just going home
yep like blankets just lost the bishop
on d4 dominates the night it will never
move in this game again and you just
pushed the edge born check page 4 well
you can approach the night this is also
good just go to b3 and pick up the night
if black approaches the night himself
who protected then you go with the
h-bomb
yeah very nicely played
now let's say h4k f7 King c2 King b3 and
resigns
yeah very convincing play we can just
take f6 if you want okay he's just using
his own pawn
yeah why this far too much head check
black resigns
yeah very nicely played he just
dominated this this night on the room
okay no he got to kill me on playing
wide against Grandmaster Guk
this is semen raucous ethic esteem oh
it's difficult to undo this English type
of pronunciations of names that you
don't really pronounce the English like
Augustine would be Augustine John yeah
the former trainer of Magnus causes and
the Norwegian number one before
Carlson became the dominant player and
we have a Kings Indian attack but with
an open Center this is slightly uncommon
but not bad for whitey it's got a nice
Bishop on g2 and some decent squares on
B 3 and C form for the Knights the
Knights are nicely positioned yeah once
before this night is just a rock very
nice piece but it's not so easy
however for y2 to come up with the
clear-cut plan what we exactly do you
attack you've got four pawns on the
queenside against three pawns black has
really happened in those pawns and where
do you attack us
it's very very tricky yeah
if five is interesting now attacking the
Queen with the bishop on CA the number
shop G for maybe even push it at five
yeah I think black is fine I always like
this
type of positions where you have those
eternal pieces like the knight on c4 but
I don't really see a good good plan for
white to get ahead
I thought maybe prepare f4 but now he
has played h4 so f-4s is more difficult
now
I'm not sure what the H pawn push what
this is some accomplishing
yeah we should d8 is probably intending
to play Bishop CSUN to overprotect f5
and in the long run allow f5 and why
does take was some time he has played
really quickly before and now yeah one
white could play play h6 trying to
install this pawn yeah the the black
king is always a factor h6 g6 and
anything landing on g7 is fatal but it's
a long way to g7 not clear it's very
difficult to get ahead here without any
pong pushes so that's only f4 as a
possible idea but how do you prepare
that even Bishop d1 hmm yeah very tricky
now he's taking some time I think he's
not really too enthusiastic about his
position you know what black ball just
played g6 I guess maybe g5 can can't
think about that but g6 is really the
normal move yeah maybe this look do you
want just yeah try to to be solid and
maybe on a good day you can you can push
deform and open up the position for the
roofs at the moment though black can
just take it and that it's really not
leading to anything
Oh surprising he went for it anyway okay
so he sacrificed the exchange
now White has this very nice night on
sea form but the night is not doing so
much at the moment it only attacks while
look said two squares like a 5 D 6
yeah the bishop wants his 7 controls all
the important questions maybe nighty 3 D
5 whether this is now gone this
possibility it's not easy to play when
whites whites compensation is probably
not entirely sufficient but he's got
active pieces night only 3 will protect
the bishop on d5 it's not easy for black
it's not easy for black at some point
you probably have to play moves like f5
and this can easily backfire 93 2nd f5 1
if this can easily easily happen
okay he's trying to get the age six born
maybe 93 Queen takes age six and then 95
interesting 53 23 does 27th yeah he's a
really resourceful player especially in
complicated technical positions
Jeff don't really see a good one from
right now the bishop on this evening
maybe your oxy form Roxy for takes b3
this motif is very important
maybe black can can do that they are not
anymore
Roxy for takes b3 is ridiculous get the
bishop is saying how do you protect that
96 all this looks really shaky widest in
those pins and you cannot easily move
the Bishop's home from d7 check oh just
just this trade ah this looks fatal we
need for every four there's a the rook
is hanging of course white reason you
know this is this is fatal
yeah white somehow or lost threat it was
an interesting position but not here
this is this looks looks okay at first I
mean you think okay white has this
diagonal and this good piece on c4 but
how do you actually get ahead and this
is only really possible with f4 he never
really got this going and that's
difficult
probably like has a very young decent
pawn chain here in the center very very
sturdy construction alright I guess this
video is quite long already I hope you
enjoyed it
being able to kibbutz a couple of strong
players some I am strim some GM's
different types of games I hope you
enjoyed it and well spend a nice final a
Christmas today thanks for watching